j'ai vu il ya une chose qui arrive de
dents de tendance et quand on envoie un
texto à une personne et que c'est pas la
bonne personne
alors c'est arrivé apparemment à cyril
viguier qui a avoué avoir fait une
grosse boulette une mauvaise
manipulation des smartphones il a envoyé
un je t'aime au premier ministre au lieu
de sa femme déjà des déjà faut voir le
bureau du premier ministre en est notre
cas on est on est plus à la mode et
c'est vrai que c'est vrai que c'est une
erreur qui peut arriver moi ça m'est
arrivé je vous dire quand je vais très
précis après une autre anecdote mais moi
la mienne elle m'a coûté bas niveau
alors en fait voilà j'étais bien j'étais
avec ma femme je dirai pas laquelle
et bah oui et donc allez allez pas les
parties à l'ets partie elle est partie
et au moment où aller où elle part je
prends mon téléphone et et j'envoie
vient vite
non mais pas mon papa la personne qui
devait venir vite en fait à la personne
qui devait partir
aucun coup téléphone abri qui le dit
mais pourquoi tu me dit viens vite
puisque je viens de partir d'une amp et
non j'ai marqué j'ai oublié ses revenus
votre histoire d'arriver parce que vous
et le téléphone de tout le gouvernement
non pas du tout non alors déjà il à la
première dame le président c'est beau à
regarder j'arrive idées j'en suis sûr
ouais déjà non non moi j'aime à gagner
vers du bordelais comme alors je me suis
trompé je me suis trompé effectivement
je voulais envoyer est quelqu'un qui me
harcèle et une copine qui voulait
absolument dîner avec moi
en fait je réponds je réponds à une
autre ami qui devait participer
elle est lourde verrou l'emmerdeuse
longue ce message je les envoyais et
aveiro ça va y aller avec tout vos
conduits à télé réalité non alors moi
j'ai fait une grosse erreur c'est quand
j'étais plus jeune j'avais deux copains
en même temps j'étais jeune mon copain
sap et laurine et l'autre et sap et rudy
ride c'est un garçon sympa bien c'est
qu'elle donne le prénom est en fait
j'avais rendez vous avec les deux en
même temps donc il y avait une fois
débrouille et du coup j'ai parlé à ma
copine et j'ai envoyé c'est bon teint
qui est paru 10 et gérer maintenant je
m'occupe de laurine et j'ai envoyé à
laurine trop alors il sait pas on
féminise non ça c'est non bah non c'est
un garçon se prénomme alors kévin
journée or mes parents vont tuer désolé
papa maman show volant tous les matins
pour aller au travail je reçois un texto
de ma mère bonne journée chéri bisou à
popol
donc là je l'appelle oui bah qu'est ce
qu'il ya mon coeur bat bisous popol
robes l'on téléphone elle m'a plu ap de
la journée c'était pour qu'il